بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم سيتم الان ضرب في
اتجاه موقع ناحي العوز وتحشد موقع بدري
للشاطئ سرايا القدس كتيبه الزيتون سلاح
المدفعيه الله اكبر ولله الحمد الله اكبر
ولله
الحمد
[موسيقى]
الله
اكبر
ابو وما رميت اذ رميت ولكن الله رمى
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الله
اكبر الله
[موسيقى]
اكبر ولكن الله
رم الله
اكبر الله
اكبر بسم الله
الله
اكبر بسم الله الله
اكبر روح روح بسم الله الله
اكبر الله
اكبر اني
ايوه
ايو الله
اكبر بسم الله الله اكبر سكر بسم الله
الله
اكبر ايوه ايو كمان واحده الله اكبر بسم
الله الله اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر كمان
واحده الله اكبر بسم الله الله اكبر الله
اكبر الله
اكبر سمي بالله
كبر الله اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
اله الله اكبر الله اكبر بسم الله الله
اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر ايو وحده الله
اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر